Let's go to our caller from the nine five
four area code.
Who's calling today from nine five four.
A David Lewis from Miami, Florida, have a
similar situation of the gentleman from Arizona.
Yeah, your Miami I business as usual.
Everyone's kind of treating like the Corona
virus, like a phase, like a springtime problem.
Now it's summer.
And, you know, as I saw the news, like everything's
kind of pointing to like almost like a second
wave.
And I just wanted to get your thoughts on
the like.
How do you what's your outlook on on kind
of the way people are taking this?
Because I guess Miami is kind of a mix of
everything.
Yeah, but it seems like everyone's starting
to go out to restaurants more.
You know, people are shaking hands like the
whole mass thing is like people I talked to
who are conservative.
They say it's a hoax.
Right.
I just want to know, like, where do you think
this is going to end up two months from now?
Three months from now?
Well, listen, I'm glad you called because
I want to talk about Miami.
Miami is one of my favorite places within
the United States to vacation.
So let's get to Miami in a second.
So the situation is there is no one answer
right now.
What we're seeing in some states is very different
from others here in Massachusetts.
And I'm not bragging when I say this.
Things really are going very well.
There are some days where we only find 50
cases and I'm glad that I'm here and not in
some of these other places.
Now, things could turn around.
We'll see if the protests had any effect on
Casey's outdoor dining has opened up.
We'll see what happens.
But we are getting dramatically different
situations in some states versus in other
states, the states that are now spiking.
So you've got Texas, Florida, Arizona and
some others.
They may not have a second wave because the
first wave just won't end.
Right.
The idea was that by June 1st, cases would
be down dramatically in the country and they're
down a little bit.
But we still have 20000 new cases a day.
It takes months to decrease the number of
cases dramatically if wave two is expected
in mid-September.
There probably won't even be a break between
waves one and two.
In some of these states, Florida may be one
of those places, I don't know.
So in the other states that are doing well,
it's going to start to be affected by our
people traveling in from problem states and
giving the virus to other people.
Like if people start coming to Florida, to
Massachusetts, from Florida, that could be
a major problem.
And do people in the states that are doing
better start disregarding the rules?
So that's what it's going to depend on now
in terms of Miami.
I just got an e-mail today, in fact, from
the hotel that I stay in when I go to Miami
Beach and they are offering 15 percent off
and, you know, saying we're open again and
it's all happening.
And it's a great and needless to say, I'm
not booking any hotel stays in Miami Beach
right now, but I am getting the impression
that it's just back to normal there.
Yeah, everything's kind of like I mean, I
wouldn't say 100 percent normal, but it's
it's weird because I feel like though everyone's
world views, it's changing.
Yeah.
And I think it's because Miami is one of those
cities that, you know, has a lot of people.
But was it like a New York or anything like
that?
So it I guess people just kind of like.
Pretend like nothing's happening.
So right now in Miami or so, are you in Miami
or Miami Beach?
I'm in Miami, like basically Miami Beach,
a couple miles away.
Maybe.
OK.
I don't know if you're spending time or in
one or the other, but so right now, people
are dining indoors with no masks and not a
reduced number of tables.
It's like the full number of tables.
Oh, no.
I would say it's probably like they space
it up.
It's sort of like candles, like in a restaurant
open, like the hand sanitizer.
But it's it's deafening.
Like nothing's up.
You start to wear a mask to go in.
OK, what's your, you know, mouth?
I mean, the A.C. could still flow a certain
way, which is.
Right.
And that's how people contracted the virus
in Washington.
Yep.
Like, spread everything.
So what are you what are you doing?
Are you are you dining indoors right now or
are you avoiding it?
I mean, I'm avoiding it, but it's kind of
hard because, like, you know, my my sister,
she might go in and I might interact with
her.
So, like, everyone's kind of doing their own
thing.
So, yeah, you might take steps to prevent
stuff.
But they, like the people around you all the
time, are doing stuff.
I mean, can you really help it?
No, you can't.
And I mean, this is why the case numbers are
what they are.
It's like the spike in floor.
It almost looks fake, like do you see how
fast the cases are going up?
And it's I couldn't even be real.
And yeah, it's real.
It's it's crazy.
And my girlfriend works for, like the Florida
Department of Law Enforcement.
She constantly told me people are really taking
it seriously.
I see the e-mails like this, folks, and, you
know, the protests don't help either.
Now, sometimes people like that.
I guess not wear a mask you because Miami
gets hot.
It's like eighty nine degrees outside right
now, so.
Man, that's such a bummer.
I was actually scheduled to be in Miami Beach.
I went I was supposed to go.
March.
Wait.
March 25th.
No.
Yeah.
Right around March 25th.
I had tickets and a hotel stay booked for
Miami Beach and things exploded around March,
you know, ten or twelve.
And obviously didn't happen.
I canceled it.
And I don't know when I will next be down
there, which is really sad because I do like
it.
Yes, I said, well, you know, that's my question.
Guess.
Hopefully things get better, but I think everyone's
world view is not helping the situation anymore.
I agree.
All right.
Good luck down in Miami.
Wishing everybody the best down there.
It seems like a very, very complicated situation,
to say the least.
We're going to go to a break.
I apologize.
I wasn't able to get to everybody who called
in, but I did my best.
And we will take calls again.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman Duchon.